[Applause]
[Music]
somebody I can I could let you know it
all night but it's such a big news week
I mean obviously let's get right to the
big story the fate of the Supreme Court
and maybe the nation hangs in the
balance
I'm kidding stormy Daniels wrote a book
about Trump's dick
[Applause]
stoked he did it's called it takes a
village to find it it's called full
disclosure and Trump says he isn't
comment commenting he hasn't seen it his
dick not the book and it's not all about
his dick but it's a lot about is dick
stormy Daniels who would know and she
says it is small but it has a big head
like a mushroom that's what she said
I had like a mushroom also it stands for
the national anthem other than that it's
a normal normal penis
let's get to the other dick in the news
Brett Kavanaugh is the this time last
week Brett Kavanaugh was heading to to
be on the nation's highest court and now
he is heading to the world's worst high
school reunion we have an extremely
credible woman a psychology professor
who says back in 1982 when she was 15 in
Cavanaugh was 17 Cavanaugh and a friend
attacked her at a party and Republican
defenders are saying that we shouldn't
be revisiting things that happened
decades ago which is what I say about
Roe vs. Wade
there are other big lot is that you know
we're judged by what we did in high
school my god none of us would have jobs
okay well you know what it's so we all
did stupid things when we were young
I sold pot in college but I never pinned
anyone down and forced the pot in their
throat you know what I'm raw more is
defense really the Republicans boy they
get in my Roy Moore is defending Brett
Kavanaugh he said what they're doing to
Brett Kavanaugh makes him very man he's
also very mad that he wasn't invited to
that party with the teenager
party party it was five people did you I
only found this out five people this
could be investigated so easily by the
FBI if the Republicans wanted to go that
route you know an actual investigation
it took a I mean it's a small community
Britt capita went to an all-boys
Catholic prep school it's the kind of
place where the kid goes into confession
and says bless me Father for I have
sinned and the priest says dude I was
there
[Applause]
but it told you the Republicans they all
get behind the same story the one they
are all talking about now today I can't
even believe this is that listen to this
this is their best defense yet dr. Ford
perhaps was attacked but not by Brett
Kavanaugh by someone who looked exactly
like Brett this is what his doppelganger
at the party and one brought a robot
double that's remember 80s parties that
were kind of like that there were a lot
of evil twins
remember that documentary about Michael
Jackson where he's nice at first and
then he's a werewolf Trump of course
standing by his men Trump said yesterday
about Cabot he said he's a great
gentleman with an impeccable reputation
and he knows this because Brett
Kavanaugh spent nine hours at the White
House the first day this broke 9 hours
for a guy with an innocent story that's
a lot of times it's been at the White
House been there all week but Trump
knows this because he says he and Brett
Kavanaugh had a long serious talk
[ __ ] grabber - [ __ ] grabber
and Mike Pence says this will keep
happening as long as America ignores the
problem boy girl
sock Hobbs you know it and Betsy DeVos
is it means we should get rid of high
school so you know everything but
finally I'm going to North Carolina over
the weekend I can't wait to entertain
the people there Trump was there the I
know they've had a very rough time Trump
was touring the storm damage in the
Carolinas the other day and I swear to
God a guy came up to him he said I named
my dog after you there boy here mushroom
dick